ارض العرب في مواجهه الكوارث الزلزاليه
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وسكان محاصرون
تحت الانقاض مشاهد مؤلمه من تركيا وسوريا
اللتين فاجئهم زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله
تسعه على مقياس ريختر فجر يوم الاثنين
السادس من فبراير عام 2023 كوكب الارض
يتعرض لمليون زلزال سنويا منها 100 على
الاقل ذات قوه تدميريه عاليه بين حين واخر
نسمع انباء عن زلزال مدمر في مكان ما من
العالم مره في الصين ومره في باكستان
وكثيرا في تركيا التي تقع في منطقه نشاط
زلزالي من بين الاعلى في العالم لكن هذه
المره تاثرت سوريا بالزلزال بشكل كبير
ووقع فيها الاف القتلى والجرحى والمفقودين
كما امتد تاثير الزلزال الى لبنان والعراق
ومصر الامر
اثار تساؤلات لدى كثيرين حول مدى تهديد
ظاهره الهزه الارضيه
لمنطقتنا العربيه
نتيجه لوقوعها في مناطق نشاط زلزالي مباشر
تتعرض منطقه دول الشرق الاوسط بين الحين
والاخر لهزات ارضيه قاسيه لكن بدرجات ونسب
مختلفه اكثر من نصف الدول العربيه تقع في
مناطق نشاط زلزالي مباشر مثل سوريا ولبنان
وفلسطين والاردن ومصر ودول المغرب العربي
اضافه الى اليمن
واحزمه الزلازل المدمره ليست ببعيده عن
منطقتنا فحزام التلاقي بين اوروبا
وافريقيا مثلا يعبر شرق البحر الابيض
المتوسط بدءا من سواحل تركيا وبلاد الشام
مرورا بمصر ودول المغرب العربي اما حزام
الاختود الافريقي الشرقي فيمتد من سوريا
ولبنان وفلسطين والاردن
الجزائر اكثر الدول العربيه التي عانت من
زلازل مدمره خلال العقود الماضيه ففي عام
1954 ضرب زلزال ولايه الشلف بقوه سبع
درجات على مقياس ريختر لمده سبع دقائق
تسبب بتدمير تسعين بالمئه من المدينه وخلف
1500 قتيل وخمسه الاف جريح بعدها بسنوات
ضرب زلزال اخر بقوه سبع درجات فاصله ثلاثه
على مقياس ريختر نفس المدينه الجزائريه
وفي تلك المره قتل اكثر من 2600 شخص واصيب
الالاف
وفي الجزائر ايضا تعرضت مدينه عين تموشنت
لزلزال قوته خمس درجات فاصله ثمانيه عام
99 ثم حدثت الكارثه عام 2003 عندما ضرب
زلزال بقوه 6 درجات فاصله ثمانيه ولايه
بومرداس ادى وقتها لمقتل
2266 شخصا وجرح عشره الاف ومئتين
وفي ثمانينيات القرن الماضي ضرب زلزال
شمال اليمن قوته بلغت ست درجات على مقياس
ريختر تسبب بمقتل 2800 شخص واصابه 1500
اخرين قوته التدميريه اهلكت حوالي 300
قريه يمنيه وشردت نحو 700 الف شخص ثم
بعدها بعشر سنوات وقعت كارثه مشابهه في
مصر زلزال عام 92 الذي كان اكثر عنفا
وتدميرا في مصر فلمده دقيقتين ونصف دقيقه
وبقوه خمس درجات فاصله سته عالم قياس
ريختر ضرب هذا الزلزال محافظتي القاهره
والجيزه وقتل حوالي 500 شخص واصاب وشرد
الاف الاشخاص كارثه لا تنسى وبقيت عالقه
في اذهان المصريين
ورغم هذا التطور التكنولوجي والذكاء
الاصطناعي الا ان زلزله الارض ما زالت
تفاجئ البشر بلا حول ولا قوه فحتى هذه
اللحظه لا توجد وسيله تنبئنا بلحظه وقوع
الزلزال بطريقه علميه دقيقه
باستثناء بعض الوسائل التي ربما يمكنها
التنبؤ الى حد ما بشيء ربما سيحدث للقشره
الارضيه